how's it going everybody today we got
some pretty cool stuff we got
behind-the-scenes footage from Avengers
infinity war plus some visual effects
videos for Avengers infinity war as well
these are always really cool to see when
you have a movie such as Avengers
infinity war where you have superheroes
that fly where you have people who wear
Ironman costumes when you have super
serious or use magic where you have a
mad Titan that shoots crazy energy out
of an Infinity Gauntlet
it's really cool to see how these are
filmed and then taken through all the
editing with the visual effects and
turned into the movie that we all see in
the theaters so I'll be posting several
videos about different behind the scenes
footage that we have received but we'll
be starting with what I think is one of
the best scenes from Avengers infinity
war and that is vanos versus Doctor
Strange and Iron Man so there's a few
parts in this video that show where the
animation isn't complete yet for the
scenes of Avengers infinity war and it
really makes you appreciate the
animators because to take it from
something so simple to something so
amazing on screen that it looks real is
just incredible but my favorite parts
and quite honestly what impresses me the
most is when you see the actors the
actors impressed me a lot because when
you're filming these things you don't
see a lot of what happens in the movie I
mean it's not like Benedict Cumberbatch
as Doctor Strange sees fan of shooting
cosmic energy at him while he's
recording the scene he has to imagine it
all not only that but he has to imagine
that he is an actual sorcerer doing
actual sorcery producing spells he has
to visualize this all Josh Brolin has to
imagine that he is this huge giant
purple mad Titan with an Infinity
Gauntlet that has essentially the powers
of the universe he has to visualize that
with the Infinity Gauntlet he is
controlling everything around him he
has to act like he really is a mad Titan
grabbing a moon and throwing it down at
the Avengers which is incredible and
then you have Robert Downey jr. and his
fight with Josh Brolin or you know Iron
Man and his fight with Thanos
Josh Brolin is wearing all of this gear
that is monitoring and recording his
body movement his facial expression
everything that they can actually take
and then animate and turn into what we
see estamos in the movie theater and
then Robert Downey jr. has to look at
Josh Brolin with all of this crazy stuff
on and has to act like this is fan of
this is the mad Titan Thanos that he's
fighting not only that he has to imagine
that he has millions of little nanobots
on him that are shaping his Iron Man
suit and turning into whatever he thinks
so it's really cool to see this scene
right here behind the scenes and the
final product of the scene where Ironman
makes a sword with his nanotech goes to
stab Thanos Diana snaps off the sword
and ends up stabbing Iron Man so this is
all just super cool to see right you
take something from the comics and you
turn it into a movie and you see the
actors and the animation and the writing
and you see it all come to life and it's
just an amazing process and it really
makes you appreciate the movie just a
little bit more so that is it for this
video I just wanted to show you all this
behind the scenes footage and like I
said there is more to come so be sure to
hit that subscribe button and the
notification bell so you can stay up to
date on all these behind the scenes
videos about Avengers infinity war hit
the like button before you leave and
thanks so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you